this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespaces the all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit
today's episode has everything elaborate
historical costumes intrigue romance
beheadings and a redhead with an
ambition that won't quit it's a tale of
tragedy revenge more tragedy and death
the most tragic tragedy of all prepare
your ears for the true tale of mary
queen of scots
a quick primer on the history of the
british isles for those who lacked the
privilege of growing up there the
mid-1500s were a time of chaos and
disruption ruled over by a series of
short-term monarchs whose vastly
inconsistent policies did little to
dissipate the bubbling reserves of
public resentment that would a scant
century later result in the english
civil war today's drama is set some
40-odd years after martin luther first
got crossed with catholicism and ten or
so years after king henry viii and
started a religious schism in england
just so he could get divorced later
henry was succeeded by his daughter mary
the first aka bloody mary who attempted
to forcibly return england to catholic
rule and mostly succeeded in just
killing a lot of people in a five-year
reign this re-reversal was itself
reversed by queen elizabeth the first
after she ascended in 1558 and also
started killing people meanwhile in
scotland james v was executing any
protestants that he felt got too uppity
and played off vatican fears about the
reformation in order to line his pocket
henry had launched an invasion to try
and encourage a break with the papal
state which somehow failed to persuade
him despite his fun new church taxes the
pope declared him a defender of the
faith in 1537 to further strengthen his
loyalty to the church despite all the
good the reformation was doing for both
the english and scottish societies the
weakening of a state theological
monopoly is not without consequences and
the wedge between catholics and
protestants deepened it might be
surprising for modern audiences to
discover how much sway the pope used to
have over the global population of
catholics these days the harshest the
vatican gets his threatening to take
away communion from joe biden but back
then the pope would absolutely declare
his flock free of obedience to any
oligarchy declared illegitimate as would
happen to queen elizabeth in 1570 and on
top of this starkly divided populace
controlling them was a motley array of
inbred ability who only seemed to know
how to get ahead in life by intrigue and
assassinations in a political system
where the queen would have her ambitions
checked by an ability hungry to win the
crown themselves these louts would prove
to be a hindrance
it would be romantic to say that mary's
father king james v died because of a
wound he received in battle or from the
psychological toll of defeat the actual
truth of war is that the king probably
drank water that someone else pooed in
and
that's all it took for every one soldier
killed by enemy weapons four died of
diarrhea this is true for almost every
conflict up until the invention of
machine guns and pepto-bismol so the
king poops himself to death and his
six-day-old baby assumes the throne that
image will set the mood for all
disasters to come december 8 1542 the
day mary's troubles began
when she was six months old england and
scotland signed a treaty promising that
mary would wed the son of henry viii
this outraged the catholic wing of the
scottish regions who formed an army and
marched her off to be raised in france a
marriage alliance was proposed between
mary and the dorphol francis and the
king of france accepted he was also a
child at the time and if anyone was
worried henry wanted nothing more than
to deny france a military foothold in
the isles exactly the kind of foothold
that scotland provided so in response
england fought a war to force a marriage
to a six-month-old girl in a conflict
known as the rough wooing that's quite
the name not really much else to say
there except for wow mary spent the next
13 years being raised in the french
court while mary's mother ruled in her
stead she married the prince of france
at age 15 and after the death of king
henry ii served as queen of both france
and scotland until francis also died and
passed the crown to his younger brother
that same year mary's mother also died
so having little else going for her in
france she headed home to take a second
stab at queenery now 18 years old she
ascended to the scottish throne in 1561
because of her catholic faith she was
regarded with suspicion by many
protestant groups but history holds a as
a fair leader who was moderate in
matters of faith now we could talk about
revolutionary agricultural policies or
we could talk about sex lies and murder
instead all right we'll get back to
today's video in just a moment but first
here's a word from today's video sponsor
squarespace now more than ever people
are getting creative with their time
they're reaching deep into the savings
account to start that new crafts
business or launch that blog so they can
share their opinions with their friends
just make sure they're not annoying
opinions the world is yours and
squarespace is the platform to use when
you're ready to get started on the next
web project that you've been thinking
about you're going to get in and out
quick without thinking too much about
what your website should look like bam
use one of their quick beautiful
templates to make a website that's fresh
and for you or maybe you're more of a
hands-on person you got opinions and
ideas about what exactly your site
should look like squarespace gives you
all the customization options you could
ever want with no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about once you're
done setting up your website tinkering
with the design if you're so inclined or
maybe just messing around with the
colors there are a ton of extra features
that squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member-only areas analytics commercial
options 20 customer support everything
you could ever want all in one place so
when you're ready to get started on the
next web project of yours big or small
if it involves a website it's got to be
with squarespace right now you can go to
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch your new site go
to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10 on the first
purchase of a website or a domain and
now back to today's video
if you know one thing about mary it's
that she's suspected of having conspired
to kill one of her three husbands let's
dish the hot gossip of lord darnley
while mary was mourning the dorphol
francis who died a boring normal death
she met a six-foot swashbuckler named
henry stewart aka lord darnley they both
instantly fell for each other which was
convenient because they had the same
grandma margaret tudor one of the house
of tudor tudors four short years later
they marry against the objections of
queen elizabeth who rightly saw the
union to her cousin lord darnley as a
ploy to strengthen mary's claim to the
english throne they also skipped over
the part of catholicism where first
cousins are supposed to seek papal
dispensation before marriage the
marriage of two powerhouse catholics now
set to rule over scotland caused the
first rebellion of mary's career the
chase about raid was uneventful the two
forces never actually met and no battle
actually occurred it was more a very
slow heavily armed footrace but it made
clear how far scotland's protestant
lords were willing to take their
protests shortly thereafter darnley
started demanding the right to rule
scotland as an equal and he took the
refusal poorly after hearing a rumor
that mary's pregnancy was the result of
an affair he allied himself with a
handful of former enemies from the chase
about raid and executed the supposed
adulterer before mary's own eyes
unsurprisingly their marriage collapsed
and a few months later prince james was
born there were signs of a potential
reconciliation mary had started visiting
him during an illness but one night
while she was gone donnelly's house
exploded and someone left his body in
the garden dead of suffocation since
that's not normally one of the side
effects of being exploded a trial was
demanded and rumors swirled about mary's
involvement eventually all eyes fell on
lord boswell her being mary's closest
advisor she even spent time by his side
as he recovered from a serious wound
leading to no end of speculation among
the queen's detractors but with no
evidence to present he was swiftly
acquitted in response the power-hungry
lord bothwell compelled some 20 odd
lords to sign a document now called the
ainsley bond which declared that the
queen should marry a scottish born noble
in april of 1567 he set out to do just
that kidnapping her off the road like
some common highwaymen are marrying her
her willingness to be a party to any of
this is an open question though there is
an impulse to try and romanticize what
otherwise would be a terrifying display
of force you can almost see the appeal
of the conspiracy angle a queen eloped
with a man who killed her brutish
husband is so much more appealing than a
narrative that reads the queen was
kidnapped and forced into marriage
that's the bad kind of fairy tale plus
even by the standards of political
marriages this one was a disaster whilst
will hadn't even waited two weeks after
divorcing his last wife to marry mary so
many catholics outright rejected it the
public was actually quite shocked at the
union between mary and this accused
murderer so shocked in fact that an army
led by 26 nobles attacked and drove
bothwell into exile in denmark where he
was tortured so much that he actually
went crazy and died mary however had to
endure public mockery before forcibly
abdicating the throne to her
one-year-old son whom she had seen for
the last time shortly before her
kidnapping as punishment for adultery
and murder she was locked in a castle on
an island in the middle of a lake you
think after running through three
husbands in under six years that mary
might be interested in chilling on
punishment island for just a minute
that's a lot to endure at 25 years of
age she lasted about six months before
escaping raising an army and trying to
kill the dude who led the rebellion she
failed and ran to safety in england
where instead of supporting her
ambitions elizabeth decided to
investigate exactly how involved mary
actually was with donnelly's murder her
cousin and royal subject
presented as evidence of barry's role in
the darnley conspiracy was back of eight
letters and a handful of sonnets written
by mary to the earl of bothwell which
allegedly proved her active role in
organizing the murder mary and her team
were denied the right to counter-examine
the evidence and since the originals
were destroyed a decade later by mary's
son historians will never be able to
conclusively answer the question of
their authenticity are they forgeries
proof of a conspiracy we will never know
for elizabeth these letters were enough
to justify a policy of containment while
mary's supporters fought a civil war
against the region to usurper the queen
in exile was confined to the estate of
the earl of shrewsbury and held under
close watch in this case close watch
meant her own private castle along with
over a dozen staff and 30 carts of
sumptuous decorations crime pays
apparently when you're a queen now with
her first 26 years being one long
expanse of death and conflict maybe she
would be interested in cooling her heels
a considerable portion of catholic
england believed mary had a valid claim
to the throne and she clearly agreed
with them and with so many back in
scotland still fighting for her she saw
this as an opportunity to grab two
crowns so no there would be no cooling
of heels you'd think that a political
prisoner wouldn't have an especially
active social life but you would be
mistaken she held enough dancers and
parties that it was expected one of them
would be the cover for an escape attempt
as dramatic as that would have been
sadly none of her escape plan succeeded
in freeing her from the grasp of english
nobility despite her failing health she
was involved in a large number of
schemes during her imprisonment at one
point a pope even endorsed a marriage
plot as a pretext for a spanish invasion
of england so often did the english
discover plots to murder elizabeth that
a number of laws were passed to prevent
anyone from benefiting too much from her
untimely death in 1584 rendered lame
with rheumatism she proposed an alliance
with a teenage son james who had started
ruling on his own just a few years
earlier in exchange for her formal
retirement and a promise to cease her
plotting she requested to end her
imprisonment despite initial interest
both james and elizabeth rejected her
terms and formed an alliance of their
own
[Music]
we talked a lot about the perils and
hardships she faced but little about the
advantages of royalty mary was a passion
icon in her day and continues to be a
modern source of inspiration mary first
started collecting her trinkets in
france when she received a shipment of
treasure from a late father included
among them was a gold mermaid hat badge
holding a mirror and a ruby comb when
she became queen she used her queenly
status to further her collection
diamonds rubies sapphires even baby
james's swaddling clothes were held in
place by a diamond cross so important
were her jewels to her the wikipedia
article about her jewels is only
marginally shorter than the article
about the queen herself in addition to
bedecking her queenly bazaar she also
used them like currency she'd wear them
to dances and balls in order to build up
a reputation about them then reward them
to friends or co-conspirators even if
the recipient was plotting against her
selling the gift helped spread knowledge
of the queen's reputation when she had
to flee to scotland the chests of
treasure she left behind were seized by
her supporters and used to further the
war effort clothing was incredibly
important in this period of history
because it instantly revealed your
social role and political allegiances
castle staff dressed in their lord's
finery because he was the lord and to
gloat their status over the peasants
dying in the fields there were no
secondhand shops where a peasant could
buy a second-hand bard's uniform mariata
comport herself as if she was god's
chosen representative on earth because
to a lot of people she literally was she
couldn't flounce around in pajamas like
a work from home slob or no one would
have died for her all the lace the
pearls the huge frilly neck whatever all
served some kind of purpose broadcasting
her power and status even though she was
essentially under house arrest
sadly all the grayson style in the world
could not save her from the consequences
of her actions the babington plot
orchestrated between sympathetic spanish
french and english catholic forces
sought to re-establish catholicism as
the dominant state religion by placing
mary upon the english throne it would
not come to pass mary's role in it was
discovered after one of elizabeth's
spymasters tricked mary in descending
coded letters hidden in beer barrels she
was arrested and put on trial in october
1586 she was convicted on the 25th of
that same month and sentenced to death
you might be asking why would you allow
someone to live in your backyard for 19
years if you know they're plotting to
kill you and the truth is queen
elizabeth was hesitant to start a
precedent of executing queens regicide
is definitely one of those once you pop
type addictions she has an extremely
vested interest in preserving the image
of queens as unexecutable it took her
until the first of february 1587 for her
to sign the death warrant and entrusted
the task to the privy council of england
six days later mary was informed she
would be executed at the first light of
dawn she spent a final day distributing
her belongings to her staff praying and
writing her will as she marched up to
the executioner's block she revealed her
final outfit black satin with black trim
sleeves and a petticoat in crimson brown
velvet the catholic liturgical color of
martyrs historians agree this served to
stunt upon her haters 19 years she had
lived on their dime plotting to kill
them all the moment she had the
opportunity and she dressed to rub it in
their faces as was the tradition she
stopped to offer forgiveness to her
executioner saying i forgive you with
all my heart for now i hope you should
make an end of all my troubles to
translate that into modern english i'm
so tired of both being and not being
queen at the same time you might as well
just kill me all my husbands are dead
and my son never rides she was
blindfolded forced to her knees and
prayed her final prayer in a fitting end
to such a tragic figure it took a few
blows to fully sever the neck and after
the executioner lifted up her head it
fell and he held aloft a vibrant red wig
illness had left her with thin white
hair which the crowd witnessed as her
head bounced around the floor her
clothes belongings even the
executioner's block itself were all
burned in order to prevent the creation
of relics the last thing elizabeth
wanted was mary becoming a martyr for
the catholic cause her body was embalmed
and stored above ground in a lead coffin
and only moved at night it wasn't until
1612 after king james vi of scotland
also became king james the first of
england that she was reinterned with the
other royalty at westminster abbey where
she rests opposite the tomb of elizabeth
the two queens never once met during
their lifetimes and now they spent
eternity with their coffins stacked on
top of each other you've probably
noticed that scarcely a year went by in
this poor woman's life where someone
wasn't trying to kill her or vice versa
there were plots stacked upon schemes
smothering cutthroat ambition and palace
intrigue
[Music]
you